oh
hello
guys guys guys check it out hitchcock
fell asleep in the break room so i put
his hand in a bowl of warm water come on
man that's the stupidest prank ever uh
no it's the smartest because it involves
biology i bet it worked already let's go
check
hitchcock no he's drowning he's drowning
favor man
i'll take it back jake great prank hey
charles can we talk in the briefing room
for a second there's a question i got to
ask you hmm
it's happening
jake is gonna pop the question he's
gonna ask me to be his bm no bn best man
is a common abbreviation no one but you
has ever used it i am so relieved i
thought maybe he was gonna ask one of
amy's brothers or who sarge hey man come
on charles
okay so i know this is a lot to ask no
it's not i want to do it you want to
cover my shift this weekend so i can go
to the white plains mall and meet daryl
strawberry at the opening of a cell
phone store
yes
that's exactly what i was hoping you'd
ask great thanks
you sure it's okay
i'm very happy about it that'll be fun
it'll be fun uh look at my smile i have
to go now
oh my god
jake what do you say bud will you be my
bm yes yes a million times yes
in your face terry what i'm holding a
sparkler for you i helped organize a lot
of this well you could stick that
sparkle up your butt i'm the best man
it's halloween
i'm surprised you didn't put on a
costume i was going to sir but then i
decided
screw that jazz
well i'm the only one who ever dresses
up no one ever gets my costume and they
make fun of me so i'm done
these people don't deserve my dress-up
gifts
charles
seriously no costume what the hell
charles where's your halloween spirit
but you guys always make fun of me i
have never once insulted you in my life
especially vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes i do remember
sir permission to sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume does it matter
if i say no no
[Music]
bam bam boom
what the what why are you dressed up you
look like an idiot but
yeah what are you supposed to be a sassy
car mechanic no come on he's clearly the
rejected pop-tarts mascot harry pop tart
i am not you know who i am squad that's
enough you're making boyle for bad on
purpose he's elvis yes elvis stoico the
canadian figure skater no
i'm so glad we could finally do this i
know kylie says you're always stuck at
the precinct
yeah
speaking of this is work sorry
what's up peralta captain called he
needs everybody back there's a lead on
the nightingale strangler we're looking
for a white male 510 medium build brown
hair small scar on his right cheek
okay his mo is he finds lonely women
with no friends poisons their food and
then guts them in his van it's pretty
gnarly
last seen wearing a salmon shirt gray
blazer
and witnesses have said he has trouble
fitting lettuce in his mouth okay
where are you apparently has the world's
smallest penis and doesn't know how to
use it hi there i'm jake peralta amy's
boss that's not true what are you doing
here i am here on a date
who is now leaving
worth it have a great night
your boss seems really nice he's not my
boss yes i am
i'm here i'm here i'm here
you can start the meeting now the
meeting is over you're late you missed
roll call and the tutorial on using the
new copier six years and no matter how
hard i try i still can't get you to
understand the importance of being
punctual maybe you should just give up
and accept me for who i am no i will
break you right now while you were out
being tardy i was hard at work devising
a special punishment i've crafted an
intricate personal high five with
everyone in this office except you what
but you hate high-fives yes every minute
of it was hell but it'll be worse for
you squad dismissed
good-bye diaz
salute into a fanny wagon goodbye boyle
the snake charmer goodbye jeffers
that's the butt bump goodbye santiago
double fist bump reverse explosion into
a pete townsend strum
all right that was terrible but it's
over now and i made it through goodbye
leonard from xerox what no no
the copy guy you're not giving us any
new cases there's nothing to work on
dammit so this is how it ends well
every ending is a new beginning
another great gina linetti entrance you
better savor these while you still can
sarge gina i am not in the mood how are
you so unaffected by all this because i
have already moved on i'm devoting my
energy to my new project ginazon it's a
one-stop online portal for my legions of
followers
speaking of hume
what's up g-hive it's queen g i'm bored
at work so i'm gonna prank all my
co-workers
that sounds like a bad idea for an
already crappy day fine sarge i won't do
it i will do it
so you can count this as my first prank
i guess on a vision
hey can i talk to the captain ugh he's
on the phone do you want a coffee while
you wait they made me an extra one on
accident oh
sure thank you
oh my god
what is that man you just drank cement
guys check back in to see if she dies oh
you're not really gonna die probably
okay just a little honey for the g hive
also you can talk to hold he is not on
the phone what is happening that's a
little something i call two pranks for
the press
[Applause]
santiago i'm on the phone
sarge i got a case for you a guy had his
phone stolen at a bar last night all
right it's not that big a deal i just
need to file a police report for my
insurance company no
it is a major injustice and we're gonna
set it right there's a crappy old phone
i'd rather just get a new one we're the
police and we're here to help you so
shut your damn mouth now tell us what he
looked like i only saw his back uh he
had a blue hoodie on whoa
we got a lead
[Music]
you just drank cement
you just drank cement it's over
yes i agree
up down
separation
separation
oh
girl you look so sad you know what would
cheer you up nice bowl of miso soup
no thanks gina i'm not in the mood so
gina is that superb for grabs scully no
my followers are sick of watching you
eat cement the precinct will not be shut
down
they decided to shut down the 7-4
instead wait i don't understand
apparently the community came to our aid
there was a swell of online support
orchestrated by an organization called
gynozo i think you mean ginazon
i was behind the bar the whole time
another great gina linetti entrance i
told you you can't be back here and i
told you i already am what did you do i
was live streaming a prank when captain
holt made his big speech about how you
did the right thing for the city i guess
people were moved they were like what
can we do to help and i said call the
commissioner's office the g-hive is real
i can't believe you did it gina you're a
legend
to the nine-nine
have a nice weekend peralta yeah nothing
special yeah you gotta come you missed
sculler's birthday
it was kind of a big one
nobody showed at the party guys guys
guys we missed scully's birthday and it
was a big one i know i panicked and said
i had to go to the vet because my puppy
cat got sick i said i had to take my mom
to get birth control pills that's better
than my excuse i said i had to go to my
girls bat mitzvahs squad we missed
scully's birthday and it was a big one i
told them i was in ecuador i think they
bought it we got to make it up to them
let's give them cash everyone put in 20
each uh yes i'll cover you hey scully
well
we're sorry that we missed your party
well don't worry about it you you all
had stuff to do yes the capital of
ecuador is quito oh anyway
happy birthday from all of us thanks
guys you're you're the best
i can't believe it the fake birthday
work
you're a genius we're both geniuses
[Music]
guys i have a great idea for a prank
before holt comes in i'm gonna put ink
on the podium where he puts his hands i
don't think he'll fall for that i did
how i haven't even opened this yet i
guess it's unrelated captain holt hates
pranks this is gonna backfire man ugh
fine i'll tone it down i'll
move his podium a foot to the left what
he'll be so angry okay five inches five
three three one one all right i'll move
it a half inch fine it's your funeral oh
my
worst
god
ever some stupid holt's not even gonna
notice good morning
you guys at
the podium
[Laughter]
you're crazy how did you pull this off
you